this is the first in a series of
tutorials on the cloud HPC toolkit a new
product from Google Cloud that automates
the provisioning of HPC environments
following our best practices it is an
open source product available on GitHub
and is extensible using other open
source tools such as terraform Packer
and ansible
the toolkit features built-in
Integrations for common Services needed
in HPC environments for example we
support file systems including our
managed NFS service file store Intel
deos and ddn luster we support
schedulers such as Cloud patch slarm and
HD condor
core and Community maintained modules
are available and documented in our
GitHub repository
we'll walk through a tutorial that
Provisions a small HPC cluster using
slurm and our managed NFS service file
store
you can complete this tutorial yourself
in your own project on Google Cloud
we estimate that it will take 25 minutes
to complete
we'll work in Cloud shell a command line
environment that allows you to manage
your Cloud resources
the tutorial will show you how to launch
Cloud shell and will provision the
environment for you
click Start to begin the tutorial select
a project and the tutorial will
automatically enable the services
necessary for your HPC environment
click show me to highlight the cloud
shell icon you may be shown a prompt if
this is your first time using cloudshell
you can safely acknowledge this prompt
next we will enable the default compute
engine service account and ensure that
it has the Privileges it needs for slim
to operate
authorize Cloud shell to use your
account credentials to perform this
operation
next we will download the HPC toolkit to
your Cloud shell environment and compile
it this step may take several minutes as
dependencies are downloaded for the
first time
verify that the toolkit built by
printing its version number your version
may be more recent than that shown in
the video
the toolkit creates environments from
blueprints in yaml format
blueprints describe your entire working
HPC environment including infrastructure
components like networks and VMS as well
as the installation and configuration of
software components like your HPC
applications
our example blueprints include a link to
the toolkit modules documentation on
GitHub
the functionality of each module is
briefly described and includes extensive
technical documentation on input
parameters and their behavior
the first step is to create a deployment
using the toolkit this will print
instructions to the screen to deploy
your infrastructure using standard
terraform commands this step initializes
your terraform directory by downloading
plugins and modules
this step examines your Cloud
infrastructure and determines which
resources need to be created
in this case we are starting from
scratch so all the resources need to be
added you can approve the creation by
entering yes
the provisioning will take about five
minutes
once your infrastructure has been
provisioned you can log into it using
the cloud console web interface for
compute engine
it will show you a list of VMS including
the slurm login and controller nodes you
can click SSH next to the login node
if you see a message saying that slurm
is still being configured you should log
out wait a few minutes and reconnect to
the VM at the command line we can submit
a basic job which will test Auto scaling
of compute nodes
three new nodes have been created to run
the jobs that we submitted it will take
about one minute for the nodes to join
the cluster in this case our jobs are
just printing the hostname of the
machine that they ran on
after the job's complete nodes scale
back down to zero to reduce costs
after the nodes have scaled down you can
use terraform to destroy the entire
cluster and bring your cost back to zero
thank you
thank you for watching this introduction
to the HPC toolkit
we showed you how to find additional
tutorials and documentation for all
toolkit modules
during the demo we have seen how the
toolkit can simplify the experience of
using terraform to provision an auto
scaling slim cluster that mounts our
managed NFS solution file store
future tutorials will focus on deploying
applications and customizing your own
blueprints
[Music]